just when you thought that Marvel and
Marvel Studios couldn't get any better
than they are now or more exciting than
it is right now with phase four and
phase five coming up Marvel drops a huge
bomb of Awesomeness on us what's up
everyone it's Warren and as of yesterday
Kevin Feige has officially taken on the
title of ce ce o-- chief creative
officer for marvel now he's still the
president for Marvel Studios but now
he's the CCO for Marvel in general and
this is really really big news and not
just for the MCU but for the TV shows
and for the comics as well and it makes
the future not only for the MCU but
really for everything even more exciting
as well
so I'll talk about all the changes that
could come with Kevin Feige now being
CCO of Marvel and why it is so exciting
and important but first be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date with the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 just leave a like and
drop a comment down below so again Kevin
Feige was already the president of
Marvel Studios but now he is the chief
creative officer for Marvel and general
before he did not have complete creative
control over everything related to
Marvel it was really just the movies but
now he has creative control and has to
approve everything that has to do with
the movies the TV shows and comics now
the comics are already amazing I read a
lot of them and they're doing a pretty
good job already
but where we're going to see a major
change most likely is going to be the TV
shows all of the TV shows that win a way
that you wish could come back I'm
talking about the Inhumans Iron Fist
Luke Cage daredevil Jessica Jones the
defenders The Punisher all of these
could make a return previously the TV
shows had a bit of a clash with Kevin
Feige Ike Perlmutter is the CEO the
chief executive officer of Marvel
Entertainment and the two of them Kevin
Feige and Ike do not get along in fact
Kevin Feige almost left Marvel
altogether when Ike demanded that
Captain America Civil War be given a
smaller budget well now anything on the
creative side has to go through Kevin
Feige the movies the TV shows and the
comics so Kevin Feige now has complete
creative control over the TV shows now
for those of you who don't know
the TV shows were previously overseen by
Jeph Loeb and they were really a
separate entity from Marvel Studios
which is why you never saw any of these
characters from the TV shows in the
movies but now they're with Kevin Feige
and Kevin Feige has been heavily
involved with the development of the
Disney Plus TV shows so what's really
really great now about Kevin Feige being
the chief creative officer of Marvel is
that he is going to be in charge of all
of these TV shows that we miss that
means some of these characters that we
know and love and miss that haven't been
around for a while since their shows
have been canceled could make a return
and could even appear in the MCU I know
a lot of you have been asking me if
characters like daredevil the Inhumans
iron fist could return yes and now with
Kevin Feige as the chief creative
officer the odds are even higher now now
of course nothing is guaranteed but
before Kevin Feige didn't really have
complete control over whether or not
they appeared in the MCU but now he does
he is chief creative officer over movies
TV shows and the comics that means
anything that goes out that has to do
with movies TV shows or the comics has
to go through Kevin Feige and now Kevin
Feige if he has any creative ideas
doesn't have to go through anybody now
the decision to make Kevin Feige chief
creative officer makes perfect sense
Marvel is moving forward in their next
phase of superheroes both in movies and
in TV shows Disney Plus is rolling out
next month and we have a lot of marble
shows that are coming to Disney Plus and
Kevin Feige success with the MCU is
absolutely incredible from starting with
Iron Man to ending with Avengers endgame
the highest grossing movie of all time
he's done an incredible job and clearly
Marvel think so as well which is why
he's now in charge of not only the
movies but the TV shows and the comics
as well so huge huge news today the
direction that Marvel is going is
absolutely incredible Kevin Feige has
done an amazing job with the movies and
will continue to do an amazing job with
the TV shows and with the comics and
fingers crossed that he wants to bring
some of these characters back from the
TV shows that we miss into the Disney
Plus line and then eventually even have
them enter at the MCU so let me know
what you think about this news let me
know how excited you are and let me know
who you would like to see returned the
Inhumans that offenders day
let me know leave a comment down below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 new giveaway
starting soon on Twitter and Instagram
so don't forget to follow me on there
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof